los diferentes movimientos diplomáticos
que hemos visto en los últimos días
incluida la visita este fin de semana
del director de la organización de
energía atómica internacional rafael
grossi no han impedido que irán confirme
que no seguirá cumpliendo ese protocolo
de armas nucleares que en este caso
consiste en que no se permitirán las
visitas relámpago los inspectores de
esta organización que tampoco tendrán
acceso a las cámaras que están ubicadas
dentro de estas plantas nucleares ellos
tienen como labor monitorear lo que pasa
con el acuerdo nuclear y el cumplimiento
el cual al cual se ha referido hoy el
ministro de exteriores iraní mohamad ya
va a salir que dice que irán sigue
dentro del acuerdo nuclear a pesar de
todos estos retrocesos que ha venido
haciendo y dice que los hacen porque las
otras partes tampoco han cumplido lo
suyo cuáles son las opciones de salvar
este acuerdo nuclear del cual presidente
baiden ha dicho que quiere volver a este
pacto nuclear del cual se retiró su
antecesor en el 2018 ellos dicen que
irán tiene que dar el primer paso de
volver a cumplir todos estos compromisos
adquiridos en el 2015 pero irán dice que
es lo contrario por el momento hay una
esperanza en una reunión citada por la
unión europea especialmente por los
países firmantes de este acuerdo en el
cual estaría invitado a eeuu sin embargo
irán no ha confirmado su participación y
ellos insiste en que washington tiene
que levantar todas las sanciones antes
de volver al acuerdo